These will be the astronomical events of 2024
in Mexico and Latin America.
I recommend you to save the video
as this year we will have lunar and solar eclipses,
blood moons,
comets and even a heap of meteor showers.
We begin with the penumbral eclipse of the moon.
that will be visible throughout the Americas
on the night of March 24 and 25.
This type of eclipses
fails to enter the shadow cone of the earth
which is when total lunar eclipses are generated,
but will enter the so-called gloom,
that is,
on the sides of the earth
that still generate some shade.
This t is not a shadow,
generates this fabulous visual spectacle.
April 08
total solar eclipse in North America
and although
may be viewed
throughout the northern part of the American continent,
the best observation site in Mexico will be Mazatlan.
In April we will be able to observe a comet
which is three times the size of Everest
and has this weird name,
is calculated
may be seen with the naked eye after sunset.
May 04 will be the meteor shower peak
called ETA watercolors
and since the moon will be in waning quarter
and peeking out until dawn.
The nights will be very dark
which will allow for better observation
this meteor shower
in which the gags are the southern,
because it is calculated
that will be able to observe between 20 and 30 meteors per hour
on August 12 and 13 will be the apogee of the Perseids,
a meteor shower
expected to be able to observe 60 meteors per hour
in the northern,
on those dates the moon will be new,
observation will therefore be much easier
because the sky will be dark.
Saturn's opposition will be September 08
and although we will be able to see the planet with the naked eye,
I recommend using a small telescope
to be able to see the rings.
The night of September 17 and 18
I need a partial lunar eclipse
throughout the Americas.
This eclipse forms when
a section of the moon enters the shadow cone
and the other section remains in darkness.
September 21
Neptune will enter into opposition
and will be placed at a fairly high point
of the Celestial vault,
is therefore expected to be visible with the eye,
although for clarity
a Telescope is recommended.
In September and October
a comet with this unpronounceable name will arrive.
In fact,
for the past 80,000 years
was not so close to the earth
and it is hoped that it can be seen
without the need for telescopes.
From the beginning of summer it will be visible,
but the best day for observation
in the northern
will be October 12
and in South America
will be visible
the fabulous spectacle of a ring of fire
around the sun
because they will have an annular solar eclipse,
October 02,
although this entire section of South America will be able to see
The eclipse,
the best observation site for the fire ring
is in southern China and Argentina.
Don't forget to follow octopus
as we will make dynamics and videos with more information
as dates approach
of these astronomical events.
And you, you knew that